finite players play to beat the people
around them infinite players play to be
better than themselves to wake up every
single day and say how can we make our
company a better version of itself today
than it was yesterday how can we create
a product this week that's better than
the product we created last week we also
have to play the infinite game it's not
about being ranked number one it's not
about having more followers on Twitter
than your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo yourself it's not
about selling more books or getting more
Ted views than somebody else it's about
how to make sure that the work that
you're producing is better than the work
you produced before you are your
competition and that is what ensures you
stay in the game the longest and that is
what ensures you find joy because the
joy comes not from comparison but from
advancement when are you at your best
I met my best when I'm around people who
believe what I believe I know it seems
silly but I try very very hard to sort
of stack the deck you know to put myself
in a position of strength so for example
you know somebody asked me just
yesterday have you ever had sort of a
bad you know engagement I was thinking
myself I'm like not really but it's not
because I'm some sort of sort of genius
are they sending anything like that it's
because I stack the deck it's because I
want to be there I want to be around
people who want me there in other words
if I'm somebody's tenth joist and like
you know I'll probably turn it down
whereas if I'm their first choice they
really want me there and so I'm more
likely to have a good engagement they're
supportive of me I'm supportive of them
and so yeah I'm at my best all right
when I stack the deck when I choose to
be in an environment where where my
strengths are are there you just watched
two amazing clips from Simon sonic take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]